à paris la manifestation contre le
mariage pour tous a rassemblé 340 mille
personnes selon la police et 800 mille
selon les organisateurs
dans le département des départs groupés
ont été organisées ce dimanche comme à
la gare de saint quentin en yvelines
xavier manifeste pour la première fois
pour demander un débat au plan national
ce qui le choque c'est le mot mariage
le terme de mariage le mot mariage pour
moi est attaché à l'union d'un homme et
d'une femme est donc je verrais bien que
les parlementaires votent une loi où il
attribue les mêmes droits aux hommes aux
homosexuels dans le cadre d'une union
civile mais pas avec le mot mariage
une trentaine de personnes patients pour
prendre le chemin de la manifestation
parisienne
dans une ambiance sereine pas de
banderoles j'ai pas trop l'habitude de
manifester mais c'est vrai que ça
m'intéresse
se défend de la famille c'est important
pour moi et c'est vrai que c'est un
un des domaines qui nous tient à coeur
particulièrement quoi elle a rien contre
contre les homosexuels ils font ce
qu'ils veulent mais les enfants ont
besoin d'un père et d'une mère à l'écart
du groupe de militants tiennent une
pancarte explicite
on est venu essayer de le redonner un
peu le sourire avec des affiches
caricature le débat actuel
je trouve qu'il libère ou paroles
homophobes qu'on croyait endormi et qui
se réveille à l'occasion de ce débat
c'est ça ce qui m'inquiète
laurent est donc favorable au mariage
pour tous il sera aux côtés des
partisans projet de loi dimanche 27
janvier